thank you so much mike the hugs are
still coming here
paul george terrence mann it has been
50 years paul 50 years this franchise
has been waiting to get to a conference
finals
what does it feel like to finally cross
into that land for you
man feels great uh the close out here um
they they rid us off when uh kawhi went
down everybody had to step up we knew we
had to step up in this loss
um we just send our prayers to him
hopefully he gets healthy
but uh we we got to continue on you know
he he uh carried us up until this point
uh i look forward to the challenge to
carry us even further
now you know from now on we're gonna
call this the terrence mann game
terence did you know you had this in you
tonight um yeah i mean i just trust my
work
i just go out there trust my work
everybody can tell me shoot the ball
shoot the ball and that's what i did
did you know he had this in him tonight
yes yes
we've been on him to shoot the ball you
know he he he works on his game so much
one of the best young players that i've
been around it uh reminds me a lot of
myself
uh he puts the work in so we tell him we
come out here you work so hard for what
come out here and show it you know what
i mean and he came in he played with
confidence
and you saw what 40 yeah 40 you got to
know what you had
i really don't know something wrong i
don't know what you had i looked up i
had 34 that was the last thing i
was a while ago that's amazing you
mentioned kawhi
being out of course we don't know if
he's going to be able to be back with
you
in this next series what can you guys do
to continue on without him because if
you
you have said paul that you have called
him the best player on this team
absolutely he is our best player but for
us to continue to succeed we got to play
together
um i thought the first half we kind of
got away from that
myself uh especially i tried to make
plays tried to be aggressive looking for
shots of my own
i just trusted my teammates i trusted my
passing abilities
um got to the paint tried to make plays
and
uh and my teammates really did they did
all the work you know i just had to make
make it happen and they did everything
else so this win is really
ghost credits to all my teammates man
well it's a very quick turnaround we
will see you guys
just on sunday in phoenix good luck to
you with that
safe travels and congratulations 50
years
the la clippers are in the conference
finals back to you mike appreciate your
race palmdale went up
thank you rachel